ils se considèrent comme des lanceurs
d'alerté pour cette opération l'alertent
aux déchets est donné au bord de la
nationale 10 aux essarts-le-roi une
quarantaine de marcheurs cueilleurs ont
rempli 122 sacs poubelle soit près d'une
tonne de déchets sur environ 500 mètres
de voie ce qu'est une mission une des
plus difficiles en effet peut-être une
bonne vingtaine et aujourd'hui c'était
vraiment le summum l'a ramassé plus de
60 bouteilles d'urines qui émane des
routiers 1 qui balance sa part les
portières ou qui balança lorsqu'une
sortent des camions cette association
créée en novembre 2018 veut nettoyer les
espaces naturels et sensibiliser à la
protection de l'environnement
cela dès le plus jeune âge j'aimerais
ville vivre dans une ville propre d'y
ramasser tous les déchets passent quasi
pro b pour la planète
cette partie de la nationale 10 une zone
déjà traité par les marcheurs cueilleurs
malgré plusieurs courriers à la
direction des routes d'ile-de-france la
situation n'a pas évolué c'est un point
qui est connu pour être très sale pour
pas dire plus et pour rester correct et
rien n'a été fait en un an c'est à dire
cap
personne n'est jamais venu nettoyer
personnes s'en occuper il ya ni
prévention ni sensibilisation éviter
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui il faut
sensibiliser à outrance
il faut que tout le monde s'y met il
faut que ça soit les élus présents les
associations faut que ça soit dans les
écoles faucon réapprendre le civisme
faut qu'on va apprendre la plus jeter à
moins consommer vous voilà c'est c'est
tellement vaste toutes les semaines les
marcheurs cueilleurs yvelinois sont sur
le territoire à la chasse aux déchets
dans les yvelines mais aussi dans toute
la france aujourd'hui l'association est
déployée dans 26 départements